ah oui ça là c'est la meilleure le
calendrier 2010 est de bâtir j'habite
est bien le calendrier il est sorti et
enfin les chroniqueurs ont voulu refaire
un petit peu les pauses ça c'est
baptiste
ah bah oui ça aurait alors ça c'est
toujours baptiste voilà dieu bénisse le
paysage est beau
non mais c'est vrai très beaux paysages
et s'est réalisée sans trucage et ça
passe à mike powell et à l'odorat qui
ont trop et c'est vraiment toi et
regarder mais bien sûr que c'est lui il
est bien lyon ils vont bien le torse
bombé le torse bombé tous les cas ça
c'est dur faire sa déposition
les muscles et on voit bien la res il
faut pas les mettre les deux là comme
récemment c'est pas la même c'est que
les entreprises et le pantalon qui
n'avait tout cela pour la la on passe
pas le même mois de septembre
d'ailleurs la jcem retour en corse ils
arrivent ils sont contents et l'arabie
mballa ça vous tombe sur le coin de la
gueule là c'est pas la même c'est pas le
même déjà là il était sur un contrôle de
maths ig2i fussent 2
j'aime beaucoup aller franchement allait
bien oula ça là je veux pas savoir qu'il
a fait pas mal c'est pas mal maintenant
j'en suis à moins de gens à -9 4 points
alors celui-là ah ouais là il faut être
costaud et là c'est quand il attendait
le bus
ah ouais ah ah ouais là lui il attend le
bus pour rentrer à la maison de retraite
ça là c'est la meilleure non mais c'est
bon sur la tête de ma mère me faisait
plus la même chose
las de ce côté là on a un mec il est
beau gosse il va faire un football
américain et là on a bonne tu tires ou
tu pointes
sous une chaleur tropicale
le cochonnet volts si thierry moreau qui
va s'élancer
il a des pecs et à l'intérieur ouais
ouais en fait c'est son corps qui veut
se barrer il a le solex et son corps il
va vite mais je me barre et gérant les
boosterait ainsi on rigole mais pas
macho mais c'est un nom qui rit je vous
jure je trouve qu'il y avait un truc
quoi là je sais pas encore bah c'est pas
milliard
c'est pas un cadeau
[Musique]